[Musique]
le candidat idéal à la mairie de Paris
existe je l'ai rencontré il s'agit de
Monsieur Devigne président du club à
Monsieur David
que veut dire
à Monsieur c'est le nom de la première
légion que coloase
elle a été fondée en 52 après
Jésus-Christ elle était quelques
caractérisée par les deux ailes sur le
casque
ce qui donne la
des directions à notre club
le côté bien français et ensuite le côté
très très discipliné ça n'est pas une
discipline stricte
mais ferme
je ne suis pas un soldat mais j'ai le
tempérament militaire c'est-à-dire je
crois à une discipline non stricte mais
ferme
notre rôle est de faire progresser la
France et l'humanité nous sommes une
race d'homme nous sommes le progrès de
l'humanité c'est pour cette nous sommes
des commandos de choc des commandos
sacrifiés je le sais mais il en faut aux
avant-postes nous nous sommes de ces
traces d'hommes qui s'appelait dans
toutes les langues des pionniers des
bandes
nous nous sommes comme a dit
la définition américaine moustaz qui
stockliote track of the civilization
nous avons le projet de deux films des
films esthétiquement beaux qui tranche
un petit peu avec ce qu'on voit
actuellement
un projet sur les montagnes et sur
Gergovie qui était la victoire de
Vercingétorix sur César
[Musique]
nous sommes en campagne électorale que
pensez-vous des candidats en présence
les candidats en présence ne doivent pas
oublier une chose et je crois que tous
longues peut-être plus ou moins c'est
l'intérêt de la France et l'intérêt de
la France profonde et notre club fera
sentir sa voix pour cela
[Musique]
mais il vous faut une force mais là la
force est celle de tous les parisiens de
tous les Français
que cette force vous l'avez maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous faites
ah bien là le cas ne s'est pas posé mais
là je crois que ça serait avec notre
club
la réalisation d'objectifs principaux
avec une certaine poigne une certaine
discipline une certaine poigne peu
premièrement je ferai appel à tous les
hommes de bonne volonté de la capitale
et ensuite l'exécution se ferait très
vite et avec une poigne extrêmement
ferme
et le point d'extrêmement ferme dans
l'intérêt général je le dis tout de
suite française français je m'adresse à
vous tout simplement pour vous demander
de m'aider à faire une France plus
paysanne
plus saine
plus forte plus belle plus humaine
je vous en remercie
aloda vaincra à l'audace
[Musique]